yeah welcome to this video playing a
brawny Mia yeah this guy who recently
completely crushed me in the various off
with with them when I had to when it
black check so now we get goes in Queens
gambit yeah that's a much more strategic
opening let's say let's hope I'm faring
better there Bishop g4 okay
you know this this opens the B file ok I
can do can go for c4 here queen bee
three of those kind of things maybe
queen bee three first seeing if I can
provoke weakness down okay so maybe I
can clarify the situation and then place
you for yeah okay so let's do this this
is just relatively simple to play
position where why it is a bit better
I'm very quickly about it's a very
standard kind of situation go a4 a5 and
trying to get get something against his
slightly um yeah this creature this
Queen side is not very much weakened but
it's and a little bit of pressure okay
that's nice now a six is very weak err
sorry b7 is very weak so okay it's going
for yeah I see there should be two queen
g5 and then what I kg three not Bishop
f1 that runs into night a three and so
on but g3 should be fine yeah he's his
out form P sacrifices here I wonder the
ship f1
yeah g3 in Bishop f5 a bit night at five
if I'm sorry this one ok small Lego
Bishop g4 now I can trade the night
right I'm real I'm sure to trade this as
it now hangs for real and wherever it
goes I can take it yeah i think the
nidus is dangerous so i'm going to get
rid of it ok my pawn there hangs so
don't mind that this also threatens Roxy
six ok I can take care now
yeah tricky very tricky situation
the next move is probably look see to be
six putting pressure on the beep on but
he has two passes there so okay that one
not sure okay man let's be quick for a
temple yeah so I don't know really king
queen g2 if this is an idea or should I
keep pieces on down Luke a one looks
better take stakes directly attacks the
a pond with temple d five maybe four
rook c8 let's do this
queen bee choices this is bad I don't
know let's do it
yeah I didn't really didn't really
appreciate but I don't really have a pin
here yeah I don't really have one rook
c8 maybe nevertheless I cannot move his
rook I hope I'm not blundering start a
dead locator can easily happen checking
here Jim
I don't know about d66 he can check me
here and then pick up this pawn
maybe this for work T to me yeah yeah
maybe this is better covers f two cows
do one so at the moment you cannot move
the pawns ok you have Queenie five some
d6 checking the pawn and create time
morning Queenie ate like Quincy six
Queen B 5 stronger around and checking
the rock and the pawns
yeah that's true
can Queen g4 I've looked deformed take
here and now before maybe check check
check
black Arizona okay well I was tense and
probably holy was at some point I really
have a bad feeling there a debt that was
was wrong something wrong okay here
that's really kind of a sharp position
with his pawns and his Queen always near
my king so around here I had had some
doubts and had some hallucinations I was
thinking that I have to really sum
playing on the long diagonal a computer
just says I'm clearly better with Queen
you one hmm Queenie one and 22 that sets
beyond my powers ok this one Roxy AJ
probably then I should I should do this
immediately i lost the tempo there but I
think I'm on the right track yeah after
here after this is I'm better so that
was strong look t6 stronger or look at
five computer once 200 gives this draw
it's quite a funny draw it makes some
sense okay this happened look at you two
here now Queen a to soco move but this
is this wow this is bad for me really
here here and now Quincy six is bad for
white what
that's hard to believe but the computer
must be right here it sets a completely
tactical position nice pawns are more
dangerous that's true Joe but he did
this and now i'm winning after Queen B 5
yeah that was I was a tense battle there
but I'm glad to have won one of those
narrow games okay well thanks for
watching